The immigration law was passed a few days ago
I will explain what will change in practice with this law
the political groups that voted for are:
the National Rally
The Republicans
and three-quarters of the Macronists
first of all,
there is a questioning of the right to land
before a person
born in France to two foreign parents
became French automatically at the age of 18
from now on she will have to apply for it between the ages of 13 and 18
and it will be refused if he has been convicted of a crime
even though he was a minor
this is controversial
because the rules of the law of the soil are in force
since 1945
then there is a of the family
before a person in regular situation in France for 1 year and a half could
bring his family
now he will have to wait 2 years
be 21 years old and his family will have to master French
there is also the implementation of a deposit for foreign students
before someone just had to apply for a student visa
he will have to pay a deposit to the French
state which he will return when he leaves
this is very controversial
because many university presidents and colleges are opposed to it
they believe that this will reduce the French university attractiveness
the president of the University of Bordeaux recalled
that about 50% of doctoral students
in France are foreigners
then there is the conditioning of social assistance
before a person could receive aid after 6 months in France
from now on he should wait 5 years if he does not work
and 2 years and 6 months if he works
"it corresponds to the national preference"
it is an idea that has long been defended by the extreme right
including Jean- Le Pen
this bill also provides for an offence of irregular stay
a foreigner in an irregular situation will now be at risk
3750 euros fine and a
land ban for
3 years this offence has been suppressed by François
Hollande because it is contrary to the
European rights
and finally there is the deprivation of nationality
a person who will be convicted of homicide
voluntary and will have 2 nationalities
risk of losing his French nationality
this is controversial because it totally breaks
the concept of equality in France
concretely
one French person and another French person with a second nationality
do not risk the same penalty for the same crime
this law is a real turning point for our Republic
this caused the resignation of a minister
and also many Macronist deputies refused to vote for it
however,
the constitutional council could
refuse a number of elements in this law
simply because it does not respect our constitution